[Music]
we look at muscle gain there are a few
particular ways that people go sideways
common mistakes that inhibit muscle gain
whether you're a first timer or you
actually have some experience trying to
gain muscle mass so number one is over
complication or lifting too much doing
too much exercise the second would be
under eating and I think that is perhaps
even more common my general
recommendation would to keep things as
simple as possible and look for the
minimum effective dose just like
medicine you're looking for the dose
that gets you the desired effect without
unintended side effects right like
nervous system fatigue difficulty
sleeping if you over train and look too
much for instance and there are a few
approaches that you can take with this
my general recommendation is to minimize
the likelihood of injury first also
instead of trying to increase
performance
what is this translate into I would
suggest if you are lifting particularly
as a novice that you consider either to
full body workouts per week Monday and
Friday where you are using primarily and
a lot of people are gonna hate this
recommendation you're using primarily
machines and you are doing two movements
for pressing two movements for pulling
and two movements for legs and you an
alternate so you'd be doing push-pull
legs push-pull legs alright and you're
never repeating the same exercise twice
and you're going to use a cadence that
is very slow so five seconds up right
very very slow or ten seconds up
depending on how many injuries you have
and then five seconds down or ten
seconds down and you're going to failure
your goal is going to be at least 70
seconds so that's depending seven
repetitions or perhaps fewer 70 seconds
of time under tension to failure where
you get to the point where you can no
longer push or pull and then you slowly
lower the weight and you're done
one set to failure so that would be one
option full body workouts or if you are
say a little bit larger a lot of muscle
mass and might
acquire more time to recover and the
stronger and bigger you get the more
time you'll need to recover between
identical workouts or lifts you could do
Monday Wednesday Friday push workout on
Monday say pull workout on Wednesday and
then legs workout on Friday and you are
not doing more exercises alright you are
still just doing say two exercises and
each other it's gonna be a very short
gym workout could be five to ten minutes
max what is your warm-up your warmup is
the first few repetitions of the
exercise because you're doing it at very
slow cadence and then in terms of under
eating we won't spend a lot of time on
it but when in doubt eat more do not try
to get super lean and super big at the
same time if you're trying to add muscle
mass err on the side of adding a little
bit of fat and then you can always lean
out afterwards but you have to look your
caloric intake when in doubt I would
suggest get something like beans
perhaps tuna or salmon and then some
macaroni and cheese and mix all that
together and have that twice a day and
you should be in pretty good shape and
if you want to get really really bad in
the gas department put on some muscle
you could try something like go mad
which is gallon of milk a day but I
would recommend you not have any
roommates in that case so simple
infrequent to failure don't forget to
eat
you